mathieu 35 ans ne va pas tarder à
ramasser ses pommes de terre il table
sur une récolte de 900 tonnes qu'il
transforme en chips une idée née il ya
cinq ans ma grand mère faisait des chips
de temps en temps le week-end je me
disais c'est marrant c'est ses chips
avons rien à voir que ce qu'on arrive à
trouver dans le commerce donc l'idée de
base c'était ça c'était de se dire on va
faire des chips vraiment comme ça y est
ma grand mère pour cela direction la
ferme familiale à quelques mètres où
mathieu et sa femme ont investi l'une
des granges après des débuts balbutiants
l'entreprise compte aujourd'hui quatre
salariés en cdi qui transforme la patate
en pétales d'or tu as sont lavés
épluchés pu trier à la main sont à plat
et à s'embrasser
ensuite on l'aimé pèse on les tranches
sont les flics dans la piteuse l'acquis
friteuse honvault puis un petit lot et
en tranches avant d'être assaisonner et
emballé ici la chips et aromatisée aux
oignons de roscoff
en tout six variétés ont déjà été créés
dans le choix des ingrédients tout est
vraiment
français on cherche vraiment de se
ressourcer de grézian en cette période
cinq mille paquets sorte par jour de
lusine pourraient être envoyés dans des
supermarchés de la région centre mais
pas seulement ça passe par nous qui
allons beaucoup sur les marchés sur les
salons pour faire connaître le produit
on est un peu plus premium donc on va
aller ont travaillé avec l'assemblée
nationale on travaille avec la grande
épicerie de paris on travaille à que
beaucoup de vos hôtels
cinq étoiles sur paris etc mathieu tiens
tu as gardé son chiffre d'affaires
secret dans un marché dominé par brett
ce live ou vicot mais il compte
diversifier l'offre en planchant chaque
année sur une nouvelle saveur